THE SOVIET AFGHAN WAR IN THE
1980s.
CNN'S NIC ROBERTSON HAS THAT
STORY.
>> Reporter: NEARLY 43 YEARS AGO
MOSCOW ORDERED TROOPS INTO
AFGHANISTAN.
OVER THE FOLLOWING DECADE SOME
15,000 SOVIET RED ARMY SOLDIERS
WOULD DIE THERE.
THEIR WAR AND EVENTUAL RETREAT
LED TO THE COLLAPSE OF THE
SOVIET UNION.
TODAY THE DEATH TOLL OF RUSSIAN
TROOPS IN UKRAINE COULD ALREADY
MATCH THOSE KILLED OVER 10 YEARS
IN AFGHANISTAN.
498 DEAD IN THE FIRST WEEK OF
WAR ACCORDING TO RUSSIA'S
DEFENSE MINISTRY AND DESPITE NO
UPDATE SINCE, NATO OFFICIALS SAY
AFTER A MONTH OF FIGHTING THE
RUSSIAN DEATH TOLL IS NOW AS
MANY AS 15,000.
ACROSS DOZENS OF RUSSIAN CITIES
MORE THAN 50,000 PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN ARRESTED FOR PROTESTING THE
WAR.
RECENTLY ANXIOUS PARENTS OF
TROOPS HAVE GUN SHOWING UP.
PUTIN'S ACHILLES HEEL IS THE
PERCEPTION SOLDIERS ARE DYING
UNNECESSARILY.
IT'S WHY HIS TITLE REPORTING
LAWS SWAMPED RUSSIA WITH KREMLIN
PROP PAGAN DAMPT THEY SHOW OFF
BATTLEFIELD GAINS LIKE KNOCKING
OUT RUSSIAN TANKS AND CAPTURING
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS.
THEY KNOW WHAT PRESSURE BACK
HOME GOT THE RED ARMY OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN.
WHAT SUCKED FOR THE SOVIETS IN
THE '80s BASS THE AFGHAN'S
DETERMINATION TO FIGHT FOR THE
HOMELAND AND THAT THE UNITED
STATES PROVIDED THEM WITH
STINGER SURFACE-TO-AIR MISSILES.
THIS TURNED THE TIDE OF THE WAR.
RUSSIAN HELICOPTERS WERE EASY
PREY.
THEY LOST AIR SUPERIORITY AND
WITH IT THE WILL TO ENDURE HIGH
CASUALTIES AND ANGER BACK HOME.
TWO YEARS AFTER AN IGNOMINIOUS
PULLOUT.
IT EMPOWERED THE AILING SOVIET
DECADE AND COMMUNIST RULE
COLLAPSED.
AFGHAN PARALLELS WITH WAR IN
UKRAINE ARE CLEAR.
LIKE THE AFGHANS, THE UKRAINIANS
ARE FEROCIOUSLY BATTLING TO SAVE
THEIR HOMELAND AGAINST MOSCOW'S
ARMY.
THE U.S. IS SUPPLYING THE AFGHAN
ARMY WITH STINGER MISSILES WITH
SUCCESS.
THEY'RE MAKING IT THAT WAY AND
THEY'RE BEING VERY SMART HOW
THEY'RE MARSHALLING AND USING
THEIR RESOURCES.
>> JAVELIN MISSILES ARE HELPING
KEEP PUTIN'S ARMY AT BAY.
RUSSIA'S ENEMY, IF NOT RUSSIA,
HAVE LEARNED THE LESSONS O